have you guys heard of Andrew tape
before no no the kickboxing world
champion no no no tons of hoes no hoes
yeah like pohos got his hoes hoes like
who was
yeah a girl shouldn't drive yeah yeah so
what was I so Brown for girls to drive
of course it is why is that I believe if
you're in a difficult situation in a
plane and the pilot the first person's
gonna Panic is the female I believe that
females Panic quicker than men I believe
that's that's evolutionary I'm not
saying it's a bad thing we have
different roles in society and life
women do different things better than
men however when it comes to high stress
environments the fact that women is
capable and intelligent doesn't actually
apply because she will Panic under
pressure no I think you're completely
wrong women are a lot stronger than you
think and we're fearless and I resent
the fact that you think that we're
cowards so if we were going down in a
plane right you wouldn't care what
gender was was controlling it no I I
seriously think you um you're a
chauvinist a chauvinist yeah because he
thinks women are not capable or not as
strong as men which is ridiculous I'm
not misogynist I'm a realist yes I get
what you're saying
can I tell you something though
you can you can speak you can't tell me
anything because you're too young you
can speak and I'll listen
all right I'll speak
um I've met female drivers that are
really good at driving you know what I'm
saying an exception does not miss listen
my friend an exception
and I'm not saying there are no women
who can drive I'm professional so now
I'm now I have to be very very
particular with my language because I've
already learned here it's early on in
this stream
when I say something I don't want you to
misunderstand what I say or try and put
words in my mouth I said
that women cannot drive right yeah and
my point was obviously a generalization
the general point is that in General on
average females are not as good at
driving as men I'm not saying that there
are no women on the planet who wait
Andrew my friend well I think women are
very good drivers and men are aggressive
drivers because they always feel they
have to prove something so again I do
resent you battering women again why are
you holding the ears down so you can
hear about it that's deaf performance
here and isn't as good as meds men can't
hear at all no only one I want to hear
that's right that's right you hear only
what you want to hear and take it from
the sisters we buried three of our
husbands they didn't listen to us I am
80 years old and I have a perfect
driving record didn't you just say the
other day that you can't park well
that's not driving that's parking
I think 99 of the world's problems would
be solved if females walk through life
with their body count on their forehead
you know what a body count is yeah how
many people a woman has slept with one
my mother oh no not your husband wait
what how many people women have slept
with you yeah that's what a body count
is I saw her have women how many men
have you slept with how many men have I
slept I'm not asking you I'm saying
that's what this is I slept with one man
not that I'm happy about that
because it would prevent because it
would prevent
all of the
disintegration of morals it would
prevent so many things about the world
did you know there's like women would be
like
to be with me as a man I don't want to
put another number on my forehead you
have to be a good man they wouldn't stop
[ __ ] these idiots and stop being
idiots and all the idiots you would
disappear all the degeneracy would
disappear families would return virgins
meeting their first man staying with him
her whole life and being proud of it
couldn't we go back to such a beautiful
age all we have to do is start putting
numbers on girls Forex we could fix
everything we don't have to prove
anything to anybody one man for me was
plenty and I was very happy with that
one man if you're insecure if you you
have to sleep with a lot of women that's
a problem you might want to consider you
have any thoughts about that do you
think like women sleeping with them you
do agree with them with him you agree
yeah I'm a terrible driver
who we're talking about it
the more women sleep with other people
it's like a problem I wouldn't know so
that's what he said he's saying like
he's saying like it breaks women
essentially no when they sleep with a
bunch of people you don't think it
matters at all Yes it matters it matters
it doesn't matter yes it does you agree
with it that's
you're talking to me
we're talking to you who's that guy
that's just who we're watching that's
Tate one man is enough I married 64
years so I was with one man for 64 years
that's enough who the hell wants to go
with every other guy yeah what do you
got to prove that's what they're telling
young girls nowadays right so that's
what he's saying is to like go back to
more Traditional Values yeah Traditional
Values aren't as popular nowadays
anybody because that's why he's not
liked anybody can sleep around but why
would you you would be a level one man
that's it that's it so he's saying if
women like had their body count on their
foreheads yeah it would solve it what
about them what about their body on
their forehead who the guys yeah guys
well another point is it's not as it's
not as important
what did upset me is this they talk
about men's mental health all the time
they pretend they care about us but it's
extremely difficult to be a man it's
very very hard to go out there and
become important as a man you have to
work your ass off it was hard it's hard
bro you need to get in the gym you need
to get money you need to be smart you
need to be charismatic need to be
interesting you have to have a nice
house and a nice car you need to be
funny you have to learn all these things
and I'm out there telling guys look it
may not be fair but that's the way the
game works I will teach you how to do it
you're not going to be important unless
you go out there and make yourself
important I'm going to motivate you I'm
not going to try and tell you it's okay
to be weak I'm not saying no you need to
be strong I'm going to tell you how you
can do it here's how you get a strong
mind I'm trying to help men not feel
depressed anymore because that's what I
do I get thousands of emails a week from
men saying I've helped them with their
depression change their way to the world
change their worldview their life's been
better their marriage is better whatever
it is my son is now going to the gym
because of you Andrew after you watch
you on Tick Tock I am helping so many
people and they pretend they care about
men's mental health and then they look
at me and go nah we don't really care
about men's mental health silence him
and let's give them someone else to
watch who they don't feel Affinity to
men are only going to follow men they
feel an affinity to there's nothing
wrong with men like me who want to live
traditionally Mass doing lives there's
nothing wrong with wanting a nice car
and a beautiful girl and to be a
gentleman and to walk through life with
honor and respect and dignity that's all
I teach and they want to silence men
like me leave a whole bunch of men out
there in the dark and then try and fill
my void with a whole bunch of creators
who people don't feel Affinity to and
don't want to learn from it's they don't
care about men's mental health they
don't care about you they don't care
about men and it annoys me when they're
the ones who are going to say oh men's
mental health men's mental health it's
[ __ ] what'd you think of that
because he got canceled like they took
his platform away because of the stuff
he's saying I totally agree with
everything he said you think you don't
think it's harder Life as a man than a
woman no no I don't I do you do because
the man has the responsibility of
supporting his household supporting his
family supporting everyone and we marry
them and we we're home we have children
we have a choice to go out and work and
make but it all falls on his shoulders
to make Financial life better Financial
yes and if he keeps if he could do that
that makes him happy and it makes his
mental health better I mean women can go
to work and help the situation but once
we have babies we're home and they still
have to go out there and Our Generations
we were home even even some when they
have a baby you know it doesn't pay if
you have if you're up there successful
it's one thing but the average housewife
who has high school or a couple years of
college and not going out making a lot
of money so some of it doesn't pay
because of what you have to pay for a
daycare well that's in this day but on
our day wasn't like nobody this day it
is we didn't have that we had a Mother's
Day number one men were I went to work I
came home took care of the cooking the
cleaning the laundry the shopping
everything he came home I fed him he
laid on the freaking couch and I did all
the work so what the hell is the
difference I did just as much work as he
did and man you don't know what his
mental state was if it was that bad he
would have been gone long ago well maybe
in your case but I think the man has the
bulk of the responsibility in the
financial system well this is what we're
talking about if that you know you put
money in a man's pocket they're happy
yeah but I put extra money in this box
yes I worked it works both ways yeah it
does it works both ways I just disagree
I think like as a man you're actually
born with nothing and basically
everything you do you have to you have
to build up these attributes with
nothing that's not it's not really true
though well it is why don't you think
why don't you think it's true you're the
man I'm the girl I mean I don't know if
you guys gonna get upset with me
I say like a woman's one of her biggest
assets is her looks yeah so if she's
born beautiful her life is automatically
going to be way like way easier or even
just you know born decent looking she
can automatically get a man to take care
of her what about the homely ones the
ugly ones yes
that's kind of like they're valuable you
can't you can't make favoritism you have
to marry the guy from Starbucks you
gotta marry the Starbucks guy yeah no I
think a man I think in general as a guy
like if you're a good looking guy it'll
only gets you so far in life you still
have to do everything else you know you
have to make your own money you have to
do all the stuff as a it's just
different as a woman you can have a guy
generation is college you know my
generation was not College those men
didn't go to college they lucky they
graduated high school here for them yeah
but they made good living I think that
Society is making it harder for women
with all the stuff they're telling them
that is is goes against what they're
meant to do like they're telling women
to sleep around non-stop yeah yeah
reverse gender roles and that's just not
what women are meant to do no and I
don't agree with that and then that
hurts their mental health and then yeah
no wonder they think life's harder
because you're you're putting the
responsibilities of a man on a woman
think of this your generation is 100
different than our generation think
about that I mean I'm at my 80s you're a
young fellow 19 years old it's
completely different you don't go to the
club with your friends I don't know what
kind of [ __ ] ass dude is letting his
chicks go to the club with her friends
without him no you stay in the house you
don't go nowhere you're no restaurants
no clubs nothing so when you guys are
married were you going out to clubs oh
yeah and bars without your husbands
I don't believe the women should be in
clubs or bars or whatever
going to a play with your boyfriend or a
lunchtime girlfriend but he said clubs
he said wait what are you talking you
mean like girl going with her girlfriend
yeah yeah if you're going to like the
players right yeah
he promotes them yeah he has multiple
girlfriends yeah so he likes to just
tell all his girlfriends to go do that
stuff together right but what he said
stay in the house don't worry I think
it's more of an expression but if you
don't want her to go to clubs
you're not going either you see where
yeah I see but then his thing is like
his status like he's you know one of the
most famous men in the world it's like
it's not as important for him to you
know like these double standards and
stuff you know what I mean like all
these famous rappers and stuff like
they're not to keep themselves out there
then be a guy with a high status being
monogamous isn't as important as a woman
no well I think it is not no that's the
women who are strictly in it for the
wealth I'm not gonna so he's fooling
around I got the beautiful house and the
big diamond wings so I'm not gonna let
him go so go screw whoever you want but
just come home and pay for my house and
pay for my car and my trips those women
aren't happy they're only fooling
themselves so you're gonna say and it's
okay for the man to fool around because
he has more I think it's different I'm
just saying I depend yes it depends on
status like as a guy gains more status
and he becomes more important it his
monogamy becomes less important in the
relationship no no no no that's why
there's so many divorces right and so
many screwed up kids all these people
with money all these people in Hollywood
ain't even in high government you see
you think they have everything
feels his face is present all over
television with so and so and so and so
I'm supposed to accept that because of
his status no I'll get more in a divorce
yeah but like you said it's it's
different with the genders like you just
said it's not as important if you have a
guy that you love you don't want to be
seeing other guys guys naturally if they
you know it does if they even have a
girl they love they can still go fool
around and come back to this girl that's
just what he's saying I know but I don't
know what kind of woman but in real life
really really put up with that unless
she really don't care about him to begin
with and just she's just giving me
everything
Sunny if you had a girlfriend and you
were crazy crazy in love with her and
she feels it's okay to go sleep around
somebody well it's different that's
that's no but it's you need to be happy
with that one she has but it's not I
just I do agree that it's different for
men and women that's why like women's
body count is talked a lot more than
guys you know like the women going
around and being a hoe means a lot more
in a relationship
women want their their partner to have
more experience ahead of time rather
than I don't know well maybe before
they're married but not once you make a
commitment but yeah but women don't look
for a guy and they're like oh he has
he's a virgin like thank God men not
like men naturally if they could pick
how many people their their partner
they'd say zero I never thought about my
husband being a virgin did you no I
never I never thought about mine either
no never thought about it but it matters
to guys
they won't they don't want their so
that's that answers the question though
of why why it does matter they wouldn't
want their wife to be that book the men
don't get ticked they get a they're
tagged as who masses and that's a good
thing but a woman she's just here
there's a whole pig yeah but that's
there's a reason it's because like you
know a woman's body count is nice
somewhat attached to her value if she's
been if she's slept with 100 men yeah
then her value is like but the man no
one is but they say he's a hero no but
the thing is once you make a commitment
I don't care if your boyfriend
girlfriend you don't have a commitment
you don't have a commitment but once you
marry and take a vow to protect an honor
and all that other you shouldn't sleep
around you shouldn't be sleeping around
because we're going to married what's
that foul mean some [ __ ] ass dude once
said to me yeah but if it's next to your
bed what if you like upset the girls
because you're cheating and gets a
machete
Pro what would a woman do yeah
slap the machine slap her in her face
one hand mache and then backhand I
perfected this in pimp school but I got
my PhD we had the practice if a girl
comes at you
you're cheating it's bang out the
machete boom in her face and grip her up
by the neck but it's all [ __ ] that's
what he's saying if a woman caught him
cheating and he has machetes in his room
that's what people were saying because
he you know he sleeps around so yeah how
could you how could you feel safe with
the machete when a girl is there saying
well no if I if my husband Fooled Around
and had a machete in bed and came home I
cut off his head both of them I kind of
something else
[Laughter]
my dad died when I was in Romania and I
had just moved my business from London
to Romania and I bought this new house
and I spent all my money this is before
I got big big so I had some money but I
spent all of it and then my dad died of
course I was supposed to go to his
funeral so I had to make a big decision
and I remember when I first started
making my money and my dad was still
alive the first thing I did with my
money the first thing I did was retire
my mom how much you get paid she told me
I said I tripled it you're not working
hard I had to make the choice whether I
stay there and focus on the business or
go to my dad's funeral and I remember my
dad's lessons my dad would have been
Furious if I [ __ ] up the financial
stability of the family and of my mother
and of my brother to just go to his
funeral my dad knew I loved him I spoke
to him every single day he's a he's a
chess player he's a logical man get your
business running then come to the Grave
do it that way if I could give all this
up now to get my dad back of course I
would so what's the best thing to do to
live without my father poor or live
without my father rich I made the choice
to miss his funeral to take care of my
mother it's paid off fantastically to
this day my mother still retired my
mother was at the time she was cleaning
dishes in the school Kitchen in Luton
and now she gets to drive a nice car and
live in Spain for most of the year I did
right thing and I know my father if he's
looking down on me would be very very
proud of me because I made The Logical
decision well first of all I think
you're making excuses how long would it
take you to go to your father's funeral
he was in Romania and it was in the U.S
so three days four days out of your life
is gonna destroy your business and I
would have went from my mother yes she
followed his dad he's not gonna no one
care one way or the other but I'm sure
deep down your mother would have liked
you there that's funny you guys all said
the same exact thing oh really you go
for the family you go and stand next to
your mother like a man at your father's
funeral but I'd be there to support my
mother and my family yes for your mother
and what does it make a difference that
the parents were separated well it
depends on the relationship with you how
your mother felt about your father if
you know your mother still really loved
your father well they were separated
yeah I know you could be separated and
still like one of our sisters well he
had a sister though so that's that was
my mom's point he also has a sisters you
got to be there for yourself maybe uh if
they're separating there's no way you
want to go to his father's funeral well
he spent like all of his money finishing
like like pretty much all all his money
investing into this new business so he
would have had to spend like pretty much
the last of what he had he also just
like moved to remain he ran a cam girl
okay business so he had all his
girlfriends come to Romania with him and
that was like at the very start and I
was at the very start though so if he if
he left for a week came back the girls
probably would have just just left and
that would have been kaput for that
whole business yeah and that business is
ultimately what made him a
multi-millionaire well it depends on the
relationship was simply going to the
funeral worth it over be like that you
know making being the big factor that
turned him into a millionaire no but Ann
Fran just made a point what's the
relationship with the father if you have
if the real if there's no relationship
with the father he hasn't seen him in
years there was nothing going on well
you know what maybe you know I haven't
seen him I agree and if they're
separated and the mother does have no
feelings and no he's gone Bonnie's gone
or whatever but if he had a relationship
with his father that's different I think
he should have gone there your business
yeah business isn't going to fold in
three days two days whatever two three
four days that he would have had to go
especially with the internet you do a
lot on that so I think you're dead wrong
if you had a relationship with your
father not to respect him enough to go
this was also like eight years ago so it
was a little before yeah
excuse me but if I were the mother and
it was a choice of them taking care of
me stay there
all right I have I have a final clip to
react to there's a guy who watches my
videos with his mother and she's pretty
big so she made a very very good point
that I loved what about their fat
Checkers remember all their fact
Checkers and how we were supposed to
trust them but when they want Tate to be
called the misogynist they don't fact
check those little fake tick tocks no
videos what a [ __ ] excellent one fact
Checkers we're out here to protect the
truth they never exist to save anybody
from anything what a [ __ ] amazing
point that was a very brilliant girl
that said that
they want Tate to be called the
misogynist they want him to be taken
down what a [ __ ] amazing Point
good-looking woman looks great for her
age she has kids who are obviously 21 22
years of age she hasn't got green hair
you know she carries herself well her
son's in shape I immediately know if
it's a hit piece or some [ __ ] video
or I know if it's a good video just from
what they look like and of course you
you can't judge a book by its cover
that's always been and it always will be
I mean yeah you can look at me and say
well you can't say anything because I
said so but
you don't know me or to judge me or to
say if I'm mean or if I'm nice I mean I
happen to be nice but you can't judge a
book by its cover so yeah what do you
guys think of Tate overall what would
you give them one out of ten one to ten
first of all it was very easy I would
give him a seven I think a lot of this
is publicity and and so the way he says
things yes the way you say things is
kind of aggressive and maybe not all
your Ducks aren't in a row and you
wanted to irritate women respectful yeah
one to ten I would give him a nine a
nine yeah only because I might not agree
with what he says but he says what he
means what he thinks so I think you know
where he's coming from you don't have to
agree with him that's right but I like
the fact that he says what he believes
despite it being so against what's
propagated all over that yeah I think
half of it I don't agree with you know
but this is ought to make us uh to get a
rise out of us so things that it's
saying is is
um exaggerated yeah yeah right so what
would you what would you what's your 110
I'll say seven seven point seven overall
in person with him we'd have some
argument yeah in person yeah first of
all we would yell at him for cursing
put soap in his mouth thank you and
friend and Patsy and Santa thank you for
coming on can we see something
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings
[Music]